one of the toughest
guys in the world oh really yeah yeah a
bulldog
oh really yeah yeah or what her neighbor
who's
uh was my head coach in the ufc
yeah yeah like when i when i was
fighting uh
uh chris tushasher who's brock lesnar's
best friend training partner
i talked so much [ __ ] to brock like in
interviews
oh and i was like and then i i won some
award i won some awards so we're at the
press conference together yeah
and i was like oh [ __ ] there's brock
yeah and then the only like
all the other coach like yeah you got
this man i'm like what and then lisa's
like i'll go with you
he's just like this tough bulldog oh
okay he's not very big but you do not
want to [ __ ] with
yeah with his specialty wrestling okay
there you go
yeah oh he was like like yeah he was a
monster wrestling
monster just like tough colorado
mountain boy like just that's his
specialty too though no i know i know
what to do exactly
but you know when it's funny when i was
wrestling and like they'd
they'd like you know you go to the like
section championships and they'd bring
in like oh my like uncle's a big dude
like
as a high school kid i remember like big
guys who like wrestled in college would
come in and it was like
i've never felt so powerless in my life
yeah yeah if they're if their
technique's good yeah and you're going
to drink strong guys like
250 it's just like you feel like when
they say ragdoll it's like i've
literally been made to feel like a
ragdoll oh really
some of these like big dudes who are
just elite but the guy on time at least
are small he's like he's built like a
fire
or even that guy like you know like no
still a monster
guys with wrestling too it's like what
are you gonna do to them he
he he was so like tough and like uh good
at coaching wrestling
gsp would fly him out to montreal oh wow
he's a big
big dude no not at all oh no big head
big a big head he's a big head huh and
gsp is known as like one of the only
guys to like
excel in wrestling having no background
in it right
yeah that's a narrative i wrestled for
like a week and junior high that's it
you wrestled in uh california but how
early did you start
i only did junior and senior year oh
damn and you went that far
[Laughter]
it was also fun wrestling like i did
189s and then jumped up the heavyweight
cause me and my little brother were the
same
like about like 2 15 220 at the same
time and i'm like
i was like i'm not gonna like try to
take the 215 spot for my brother
so i would just wrestle heavyweights and
it was an interesting style of wrestling
because it's like these guys aren't used
to
shots you know what i mean like
heavyweights wrestling yeah so i
actually did
pretty well against other heavyweights
just because a lot of times it's a
different
style they're not used to like whatever
shooting on legs doing fireman's carry
[ __ ] like
a lot of guys the heavyweights now are
monsters but they're there sometimes you
watch heavyweight like i'll watch the
collegiate
uh tournament yeah sometimes those
heavyweights it's basically sumo
wrestling
like sorry we're just trying to it's
like big bodies it's like two elephants
like trying right pushing that
on a high school level this style is
like just pushing on each other
yeah you get some freaks yeah we're like
that is that just have the flu you get
some freaks like steven neal
he he beat brock lesnar he's the reason
brock was in a champion but he beat
brock lesnar there they are
oh big head but he uh
uh stephen neal beat brock lesnar and
then he was national champion
all-american didn't play a down of
football because he's so big and
athletic had good footwork
he got drafted by the patriots oh [ __ ]
just wow and then was like the starting
left tackle for them for a long time
that's insane it's
[ __ ] just like that and then some
some new some new guy just got drafted
too
wrestler oh really yeah they're like oh
you're big and strong
yeah yeah and i mean it does give you
incredible like sense of balance so i
could see that there's
some other balance christian
chappelle mentioned how you were looking
swollen you said i said something when
you first started working for me that
made you self-conscious
yeah uh when when we first started at
like king the sing uh
when i told you i was a middle
linebacker you was telling me basically
you know you were like making comments
so that i looked like a pop warner one
yeah and then i needed to get on some
stuff to get bigger
and harder you ever seen a little like
you i don't know
you would be small for a middle
linebacker oh no no i'm not saying he's
wrong it just hit home oh did it really
yeah was this high school you played you
were middle
oh yeah i was like my freshman year when
i was middle linebacker the
heaviest i weighed was 125. and state
champs uh
no we didn't win any championships when
i played there but it was always me
our our team and our our rival school
that was always in the championship
the rival school one of the kids just
got drafted 26 overall in the nfl draft
did he pay for where'd he play college
in michigan oh he's monster
yeah i bet he's [ __ ] on you guys um i
played one play against him freshman
year yeah what happened
uh he ran me the [ __ ] over and to this
day
i still don't know what is going on um
so yeah he's getting paid to play
football yeah you know it's like
you see those guys like oh okay
they're gonna make a living doing this i
better get in there wait if you were
coaching this team would you make him
middle linebacker
i no i i don't know i listen
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what the rest of the team looks like i
don't know
everyone was big it was a d1 high school
um and d1 that so that's like five eight
in colorado
the big boy this wick we were the top
football high school in our state like
one of them
i was like i was like third string for
varsity but like i don't okay
i thought you were starting no no no no
i did get i got way more playing time
than i should have at my size
uh like i played like at least every
like at minimum
minimum two plays a game for varsity
feel like the movie rudy
yeah that's what my team called me mine
rudy
was offsides i was also 45 which was
what rudy was
my football number was 45. i didn't even
know that
you're you you're uh you're scrappy dude
yeah i would find something for you my
my coach called me the cockroach because
okay i would get well no like i would
get like i would do this okay roach
um i would do like battle drills with uh
like the rd
like our starting linebacker who is i
think about 205 in about
5 10. he got some cd and oh my god yeah
and like our running backs too one of
the running backs was actually kind of
bill like chappelle
and there was this one play where he ran
me the [ __ ] over i slid like five yards
on my neck
and somersault it popped up on my feet
and it was facing the wrong way
my coach had to come in and face me
towards plays like are you okay to
finish this as a brain drama yeah yeah
did you guys win that game
it was practice i had blacked out in a
game like from
head trauma he said did you johnny play
football too no you were only football
player oh no my oldest brother did when
he uh at prep school but he was like a
kicker and a
tackle so nothing serious oh he could be
a kicker he's a fat kicker
yep wow yep yeah but we mainly like i
played across
football that should have made yourself
conscious though like no i'm gonna
realize the middle linebackers like like
university of colorado middle
linebackers didn't look yeah no no i
didn't like making like self-conscious
like oh [ __ ] like it just made me like
uh
[ __ ] i gotta get you you're just like
[ __ ] you don't give a [ __ ] yeah
you're that guy you're a guy
that just like i don't give a [ __ ] what
middle linebacker yeah i'll take it but
we got self-conscious at zoo when we
first started
oh yeah i don't give a [ __ ] don't worry
about this on my arms yesterday yeah i
was yeah
yeah i know you were you had some thick
arms
were you sleeping down the bat like yeah
you got a lot of muscle yeah
there's no reason to be so conscious at
zoo though a lot of guys take their
shirt off to work out though it's like
one of the things that's unique about
zoo culture is you're not going to go to
24 hour fitness and scene guys just like
peel it off the only other place is
gold's gym in venice yeah
but even but not as much it's a lot to
do for the amount of
guys that are in there and the amount of
shirtless guys or just kind of it's just
casual
no name and then we like when i first
came you know especially growing up in
gyms like i'd see something like goddamn
shirt off all right doctor
yeah now i don't bat an eye to it right
and also it's like there's
start showing you showing your arms now
and [ __ ] yeah daddy's gonna i see you
though
but i was but like krishna i was
self-conscious like i was like oh god
i'm the ugliest one in the room
yeah remember when they were shooting
that video and like hey [ __ ]
oh that's the shots that were just
[ __ ]
like you're [ __ ] the whole shot yeah
we haven't seen them since
we haven't but then but this is weird
like there's those two you do gesture if
you notice
they you know they're like the malibu's
most wanted white boys oh yeah did you
see that he was like real skinny took
your shirt off like yeah
yeah don't get carried away
yeah that's the culture there is like
it's okay to do that take it off get the
content whatever
i would still just never do it there's
some you know it's like i feel like you
would never do it
but you could do it though i would yeah
but i wouldn't feel comfortable because
it would just feel weird to be like i'm
gonna lay like i'm already sweating all
over the [ __ ]
you know i would just feel a little bit
like a tool a little bit
but i don't judge the guys like some of
the black dudes are doing like god
dawg all right that boy is born
yeah god when they're doing that was
huge
uh he had the army backpack oh yeah he's
jack yeah but then you know the short
king squad the little
it would be jackie chan 2.00
thighs you guys are the same size yeah
that kid yeah oh i've seen him he's
worked out with my uh
friend before oh look at him as a little
boy dude
he's been at it for a while now in
person because there's he's one of the
most hotly requested like everybody will
do
these videos on whether he's natty or
not this is not something i think about
a lot but in person you know i think you
see this like the lighting and the this
and that
he looks more shredded and sort of more
unnatural in these photos but in person
he doesn't like to me he looks like he's
nice that's achievable yeah
because also you gotta get him 14. i
don't think his dad's [ __ ]
putting d-ball no
he's like you're like 18. but again he's
been at it for so many years his diet's
impeccable you can see how
you know he's he's super low body fat
this could be you
know this had a trend y'all the same
height i don't want i don't want to be
that big though
like i don't want to be no wait but like
you said you wanted to gain
40 pounds last time i saw you yeah but
like that like over like a year
like not like falling like once you're
dude or like however like long yeah
you would have to eat more i've been
eating so much and it's been making you
feel sick you'd have to call the rock
and say take the wheel yeah
you yeah you would have to you would
have to eat more trend below for sure
yeah yeah i've been like i've been
dude i used to never own everything by
the way in a year
it might be a very unrealistic goal okay
then however long it takes then i don't
really know like
but he's just going away this is hard to
gain that weight like oh my god
what about you what about 20. 20 in a
year yeah but also
this is going back to the hollywood
thing we said before we have this idea
of
20 pounds of muscle the only real way to
tell that like you could
if you see a bodybuilder on stage and
he's at a certain body fat percentage
you can be like and
five years later he gained this much
stage weight because otherwise it's like
you can gain 20 pounds this weekend is
it all muscle yeah no
you could you could retain water you
could even take you know as you talked
about certain anabolics will make you
gain a bunch of
water and it enhances your strength but
it's not real muscle
you don't even it's not actual when you
take creatine monohydrate you put on
five pounds yeah
so mark what would be a realistic goal
for me for like in a year five pounds
no but i fluctuate like five pounds like
five like i said five pounds of real
lean muscles oh wow
five to ten pounds on the high end um
of like yeah at the same hydration level
okay
in a year in a year yeah but again it
doesn't sound like a lot because
you we have these hollywood standards of
like
in three months i gained 25 pounds of
muscle while dropping six percent
of my body fat which is it's just a lie
and it's impossible and you can make
aesthetic changes but if you were to
really look at how much muscle somebody
gained by looking at the exact same
like body fat and hydration levels you
know what i mean if you stayed at 10
body fat and you were
the same level but for him let's say you
put on 10 pounds of muscle right
i'll say it's not going to be straight
there's going to be 10 pounds of muscle
but then you're also going to put
probably other weight on yourself as
long as i look good i'm okay with that
if i put it on a little extra weight
dude you need to hang out with that
17 year old freaking i showed you with
those leaf legs
and all this [ __ ] bro stevie don't work
out come to the gym
stephen you know i love you listen i
don't know his personality is i don't
think it's great
he seems really nice but you know i
don't think he's gonna get us to mars
he's so in his own when he works yeah
he's so in his own
life so how tall is this kid five five
five five okay
what are you five five five five yeah
he's probably around there you guys
would be so cute together cat
i mean a two tiny asian cup two tiny
asians
he looks kind of mixed no i don't think
he looks like a little mix
what'd you what'd you say chin i said oh
gosh five three no he's not five three
ah he's short man i said people sure but
i don't think he's five three dude him
in a squad
there's not one so i call them the short
game yeah not literally the short kings
they're i think they're all asian-ish
like they're mixed one of those
not one over five yeah and they're just
like
i think one of them is his brother makes
sense he's like his film guy
and there's another guy that looks like
him that i don't necessarily see he
looks like
but then there's one guy who's uh he's
built like uh
one of those little uh schnauzer dogs
little little legs
his little legs and a big body but he's
still like five four feet
his legs are like this yeah it's so
funny you know if you made those mares
like
yeah the funhouse mares that's what he
looks like all the time
but they're cool man yeah and that's the
thing about zoo as you were saying you
were self-conscious at first but then
you probably feel more comfortable
because everybody's so nice and
everyone's nice
welcoming again nobody's like and no
one's benching 425 but yeah everyone's
nice
everyone's nice also be cool exactly
yeah on that 425
what's up daddy i know that [ __ ] was
insane
thanks man when i was filming i just go
holy [ __ ]
yeah i was like holy [ __ ] i just got it
in the rant yeah i know i was like
i didn't think i was gonna get it oh
really uh
i didn't feel great yesterday yeah yeah
we'll post it in the video
yeah yeah you'll you'll see what's up
when i i did
uh two beers one cave with sugar because
brick chrysler's shooting a movie
and he's like he's like i see you on
instagram he's like
400 pounds why i'm like i can't tell you
dude
just why not why not why not every guy
who ever picks up a weight it's not only
there are certain things that guys dream
about benching
over 400 pounds and having the four
plates on a bench yeah is a very very
common
aspiration that many men will never hit
but in other words every guy who's
lifting goes i know why you want to
bench four plates
to bench four plates yeah why not
i mean you [ __ ] did it so what yeah
i'm chilling on my 315. mm-hmm you've
got it
for four though i i just just certain
things that i think about
you know technique uh-huh you know i'm
gonna get i'm i'm
my goal is five my goal is five five
players how many did you yes no uh
four five i did you did four yeah
yeah yeah five's easy yeah you should be
able to get five hey i said little goals
so i'm never disappointed yeah a lot of
anxiety today ty going to new school
oh saw johanna uh joanna's post he looks
like a teenager now i know he looks like
a full-grown fourteen-year-old
yeah i didn't post anything on it too i
don't today's
first day at camp right first it's like
it's it's the
school will be going to kindergarten
through 12th grade
and then look at him there look at that
a little champion
handsomeness little monster is that his
little diploma in his hand
yeah that's my height
yeah go to new school but the new school
it's weird to me i was like so we're
just gonna drop them off like yeah they
just
you you know the way they do it because
of covid you pull up
the teacher comes out and gets them then
he's off i mean you don't really know
these people
right you're just going to take the kid
for the i get at 3 30.
and then i would i'd say normally you'd
come in and do like a little bit more
yeah like
when he first started uh school he was
really young
like uh joanna had to stay because he'd
freak out but if he saw her in the
mirror he was cool
then after a while that goes away so i
was worried i had such bad anxiety this
morning the worst anxiety
and then pull up teachers like all right
tiger let's go he's like bye
see you guys and just like took off he's
not one of those kids who cry and don't
want to go
yeah it could be worse yeah how big is
he going to get
like they the doctor said minimum six
too short he's not bad
minimum minimum minimum he's gonna be
six two in five years
he's gonna be six two and five years a
problem
he's gonna dunk on your ass too no he
will he'll don't
dunk on daddy what's the earliest you
can get him into football
that's a good question like tackle
football yeah i started at seven
and it's different in different parts of
the country right because yeah like but
especially now like this woke culture
and like now and and also with science
you know science it wasn't more short
science like it was
yeah it's like you got to learn the game
yeah
i don't know like a kid should start
tackle football some people are saying
never
some people say there are some say
you're not supposed to have any sort of
head trauma because your brain's
developing yeah you know
with the frontal lobe so after 21. but
then
it's like just having to play flag
football i did that for a year that
doesn't count yeah what do you mean it
don't count
so that don't count me as a football
player because i play flat because
tackling is so important
like yeah they have to learn to learn
how to i mean i don't know if i ever
learned to tackle properly to be honest
like
because you know and i know i was taught
incorrectly at least
the first few you'd have people like
these old how old were you i started
playing at 14.
okay um even that that's a little late
for football yeah
most you have an advantage if you get in
early and just know some of the
fundamentals of the game but like
dude people would teach me the most
[ __ ] up things attack but come in with
your head down and this is yeah they
teach you all these
you know really you know it's almost
like olympic lifting like if you can
learn to like
explode your hips properly and like let
you squirm up somebody
yeah if you can do it from the gentleman
build good tendencies then it kind of
helps you down the road
yeah and it even helps you with your
head like you know you're not going to
have as many hat on collisions if you're
tackling
correctly you shouldn't be going head
first but it's almost unavoidable
you know if you're having that many if
you're on the line don't they get in
trouble now in the league like if
if you go ahead and like right yeah
there's rules now
yeah but still would you say like it's a
practice and like also pop
money there's no yeah it's just it's
just
unavoidable at almost every position
maybe you could be like a receiver and
and
avoid contact most time until you get a
little monster yeah nobody can touch you
yeah but he's not playing unless he's
gift did you play
fullback nah at in college yeah
like h back full back like i touched the
ball but um
in high school i was tied in yeah and
then middle school i was
uh linebacker yeah so every single play
because what i tell people like as a
d-lineman or an oh
you know tight under o-linemen every
play has physical contact oh yeah you
know
and often that's the word is coming off
the line you're both the ones with the
with the worst ct like the worst brains
are
offense and defense climbing because
every single time there's
just nonsense there's not these huge
explosions necessarily yeah but
yeah it's the repetitive that's why
boxing's more dangerous than mma
because the constant jab to the head
constant it's not the big shot
like mma big shot you know obviously the
concussion
it's the con you get a little concussion
they keep doing it keep doing it keep
doing it
you get knocked down you get eight count
pop up obviously your brains and just
keep doing it keep doing keep them
it's crazy yeah i'm glad i didn't do any
of that [ __ ]
yeah there's no kind of there's no
concussions in uh cheerleading uh there
is
but if someone drops you or something
yeah well like if you throw someone in
the air and like
that [ __ ] comes down wrong like it you
yeah
i've had a girl elbow me in the head and
[ __ ] i puked right there goddamn becky
yeah they like fall oh there's one we
were at nationals and uh
we were doing a pyramid i was trying to
catch this girl's foot to throw her back
up or some [ __ ]
and then uh her foot slipped and it
uh her foot like her big toe stomped on
my eye
and i thought my eye was just watery and
it was like gushing blood oh damn yeah
yeah wow
so there are legit yeah there's some
like legit like there's a you know with
cheerleading there's a lot of like uh
spring angles uh acls sporty names
that's right
i wasn't even trying to be funny i
figured like a lot of yeah a lot of jam
fingers
that's my face no there's a there's
jeffy but like a lot of like acl
injuries mcl stuff like that you know
but the technology is better uh here for
like the acl stuff because
usually now no there's guys like adrian
peterson tore his acl came back like a
year later like
that's what i'm saying it wasn't like
that like back in the day that was the
most
more common injury that i knew about
introverts not your acl was yeah it was
blowing out that [ __ ] from the tumbling
like twisting in like landing it's a lot
of explosives
yeah yeah and then like you know and
then like yeah the
the concussion [ __ ] you don't have knee
problems now though
no you have any injuries you have an acl
reconstruction oh
oh damn daddy oh yeah yeah i saw this
that scar yeah
i've never noticed it yeah and you know
it's funny because
i do still go all the way down on squats
and uh it just i got hit like coming
around the corner
you're like like a left tackle like sort
of like like you know they dive at you
like if you're like beating them they'll
sort of like dive to like cut you off
and it's like
as i'm coming around this way he just
hit my leg
you know like inside like that you knew
immediately huh yes i knew i mean and
then
i was funny because the i was on the far
side of the play and the quarterback
like
um uh ran around the uh
sorry i was on the far side of the play
he he ran maybe it was an option or
something but the quarterback ran
down yeah he rolled out and and ran for
touchdown
and i'm like writhing in pain on the
floor and in the video you could see my
coach
get the [ __ ] up harley get the [ __ ] up
like that's so humiliating come on
like it was like that i was giving up on
a play but i would always like from the
back side i would always try to chase
people down like yeah i could like i got
a lot of tackles that way so i wouldn't
i'm not the kind of guy but uh when when
when you're in high school did you think
like was the plan to go the nfl no
not at all not at all so that almost
like
because i was like playing it like i
guess i'll do this
and then i just like i was just
something you wanted yeah i was doing it
i almost played water polo you know what
i mean because i've been like a
competitive swimmer and like
like somebody was like you should play
for a second i'm like can i do both
stupidest ideas right
yeah i had no idea but um
so only when i was like a senior some
colleagues were expressing interest and
i was like oh you can use that to like
get into college but i had no
um expectation of it so it just felt
like a nice bonus from like you get to
play a little bit longer
there's not that pressure on you yeah
because yeah
right because you were starting from a
young age and had all these you know
yeah so much pressure yeah i was like
what would your folks want to do
uh you think everyone did oh everyone oh
yeah yeah
she was just it's just big time football
and it's like that's you know especially
when you play at cu like
yeah that's the move man [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah and so just i'm gonna comment on
my perception of a couple people who
like went to big colleges and then
out of that like you know maybe one or
two people go to the nfl from guys i
knew who were just like
monsters so dominant and even this guy's
this guy allen anderson
who went to oregon and he was just like
shh this running back who was like
you just couldn't touch him yeah in high
school he goes to oregon and it's like
oh we're going to move you to cornerback
and he was like a good kid he actually i
think i looked this up recently
he had the fastest 40 time in oregon
it's like four three something but he
was like he was
fast as [ __ ] but he's only like 185.
yeah oh we're gonna put your corner back
you i you know would return some kicks
for touchdowns
couldn't make it to the nfl like you to
see someone who's so
[ __ ] dominant in high school and then
you've been good in college but you're
like
the this like the gap between him and
other kids in high school was insane
this other dude travis the boy
actually made he went to hawaii it was a
defensive end and just gigantic
yeah uh did play in the nfl i think
maybe even won a ring or something with
one of these
you played for a few different teams
like you know what was a titan's one
year
something he was on like a super bowl
team or one but he made it
he did and he but he was just like
tied in i remember he was playing tight
like similarly dominant but not
necessarily the guy who you like alan
amundson was like [ __ ] on everybody
but yeah
just like when you think of all the
people i know one dude i know it's not
one dude it's [ __ ] nothing the gap
from college to nfl is like
even that yes because you can be
dominant they say it's the biggest gap
in like
professional sports going from college
football to professional football
yeah they're grown men yeah yeah and my
college
football coach this guy robert karen who
went to harvard
and then played like for the colts and
he was like
you know when i first got on the team he
was like 50. he was like still
so competitive with everybody i think
you [ __ ] he would grab a face mask
and like
like he would always like asserting his
dominance like as a coach
which i didn't mind but he was like you
could just tell like this guy is a
[ __ ] animal a super smart guy would
also like be like you know correcting
you about things like
actually uh historically speaking like
you know yeah
he would always like be like i'm smarter
than you i'm better than you football
you know and he was aggressive um a
super aggressive um
alpha male 1 yes it's like it's like and
this is the kind of archetype of guy i'm
not saying
that you have to be like that but like
when you meet guys who've like made it
in the nfl it's like
that was their whole [ __ ] world just
to even be a journeyman you know what i
mean
like you're just it's nightmare so i'm
glad
coach is still coach like that no good
question like grabbing faces and
yeah yeah now when i tell people about
him like i didn't mind because like you
know what he [ __ ] cared
you know what i mean yeah he worked yeah
and he'd be like the reason he was so
he'd be like if people were [ __ ] up
or you did something wrong he was like
we gotta get it right and i'm guess that
you're not doing it right
honestly i don't think that's the worst
thing a kid could go through is no it's
being coached like that and you're not
gonna get that anywhere else right
it's like it taught me how to be like
somebody can be up in your face
screaming and telling you you're doing
something wrong and it's like okay
so the tigers are in high school playing
football like with it
yeah like i mean in the comments
yeah ooh probably yeah see the coach you
can't really do it now because everyone
has their phone out they're gonna go
viral he's getting fired but that's like
one moment out of like you [ __ ] up and
like
yeah are you driving one time and he's
like why the [ __ ] did you go out there
on the wrong special team i'm like
my bad and he's like oh good you know
and it's like over
but yeah like he says like slap our
helmets like yeah real
open hands slap to the helmet yeah you
can't do that anymore damn that's so
crazy
but you you probably couldn't handle it
if it yeah i'd be tough
you know if you were watching tt
practice it would be tough yeah be tough
yeah be tough damn but again that's on a
college level
you know and it also just i feel like it
some people hated it and quit
i i felt like it added to like
especially at a d3 school where it's
like you could treat it like a joke
like who gives a [ __ ] if the coach
really cares that makes you kind of feel
like
yeah i care too more than you would have
yeah it's not like a club team
yeah yeah so it gives it were you this
size like were you bodied up in high
school
in high school i got up to like 220.
yeah so not that much
like smaller than you know yeah i was
like what are you what do you think
40th yeah about 45. so how tall
how tall were you six three six three
rounds three by like 16.
[ __ ] that's a big [ __ ] kid no i
was a late bloomer okay senior i was
like six one-ish
okay yeah like 175 yeah but i think i
started high school at 160 and got up to
like 220
and then you know giant
yeah no i was just laughing i was like
that's [ __ ] huge
massive 160 freshman year you said yeah
but i was always on the skinnier side
you know what i mean like
i was yeah and then i and then i got
into lifting weights and eating a bunch
and that's what i was
like good at is like figuring out how to
like bulk and eat a lot of calories
that was my amazing question yeah yeah
no you can't get in that way but that's
also like me going through puberty
gaining maybe a few inches like
that's just growing up well the last
time you and i talked you told me to
like to track my calories more by like
my fitness pal i've been doing that a
lot more
yes and like at the end of the day like
i'll see like if you eat this much
you'll see how much you'll weigh and
it's been
going up and up and up but i feel
[ __ ] awful some of these really
yeah because i'm not used to eating that
much oh yeah i
try i eat like a lot of salads and [ __ ]
no no he needs
calories yeah yeah well yeah to gain
weight and put yourself in a surplus it
is somewhat uncomfortable and i remember
i used to like so there was one point
where i was eating 500 grams of protein
a day and like
you know five or six thousand calories i
don't recommend that it's just like it's
like airing on the side of like were
eating like pizzas and [ __ ]
i mean wouldn't be super gross you know
take down an extra large
but to get the six on calories like
you're gonna have to eat yes i would eat
calzone
like that oh i love calzone you know
just to get the calories
up but but knowing that like yeah if you
hit these you can't
eat too much junk to if you're getting
like a goal of 500 grams of protein
that's
2 000 calories of just protein you know
what i mean so if you're hitting that
it's just
i would eat every two hours at first
you're like
i can't do this i'm gonna throw up
eventually your body gets used to it and
almost as like every two hours he's like
i want to eat again
yeah so you can adjust both ways you're
working out now
christian yeah i go every day yeah
that's why i said you look you look more
appreciative of that thank you yeah but
i don't say that about people
i appreciate that but yeah i go uh every
day i've been like i usually try and get
uh eat a protein bar in the morning
before i go and then i'll have
uh muscle milk mixed with uh protein
shake after and then
i'll have like another protein bar or
something are you eating your body
weight in protein or more
um that'd be easy right yeah i think i i
i'm trying to cloud it like
what are you 140 i'm with 140 yeah
if you're if you're eating in a caloric
surplus
turns out you don't like people how much
protein should you eat
you actually need more protein when
you're in a caloric deficit
because your body is like looking for
anything to
break down and fuel itself so you have
to keep the protein super high
like maybe up to 1.5 times your body
weight so that your body doesn't use
uh its own muscle to break down you know
into a fuel for you know activities
right
so when you're in a caloric surplus and
you're eating more carbohydrates and
your body has that readily available to
burn
you can actually get away with only
eating like a gram per pound of body
weight okay
you know yeah yeah yeah are your dms
like this too mark like your dam's just
filled with dudes like hey man i only
gained 30 pounds
no advice most people want to lose lose
weight
but maybe like 80 percent lose weight 20
gain weight and
and they're just all blowing you up in
your dms about it yeah
yes and i'm sure you get some [ __ ] talk
in there oh of course yeah yeah
of course but he is so funny with the
[ __ ] talking yeah yeah
people try to come at me but it's like
if you come at me with your actual
profile
it's like if you're coming at me from
like zero followers zero posts it's like
i'll still roast you because like you're
just saying the same three things over
again it's like the moment you came to
my page to dm me it's
like why did you have to hide yourself
you seem upset about something could it
be that i'm existing you know
i like when they try to call you trigger
oh yeah
it's like you wrote me i'm triggered
because you came to my page and felt
compelled to write me a message
it's a weird world especially because
like
yeah so i'm trying to like help people
like get in shape and you're upset by
that
yeah it has to be something i'm not
[Laughter]
sometimes they try to call you failed
actor oh all the time but it doesn't
make any sense would you fail at
i mean like again if i was brad pitt and
just won an academy award to be like
[ __ ] you didn't win one this year yeah
you know
everybody's a failed actor if you're
talking [ __ ] online everybody's a failed
actor i don't know i mean i make money
acting
like yeah you know like i don't have
this expectation for myself of like
if i don't win an academy you know it's
like yeah if i get roles and make do
commercials and i'm on tv which you know
and you're making a living anytime
somebody's telling me
call me a philadelphia yeah you know um
once you check me out on the three
commercials that i have running right
now or uh
nickelodeon does it ever bother you or
you just got no because
you look different so you probably grew
up with him
well what i was going to say you look
different
he looks
like you have an exotic look so i'm sure
you grew up with right
for sure when i was when i was younger
and people would make unflattering
either comments or comparisons about my
appearance it's hard not to take it
personally
and then you legitimately just realize
one day you're like
man it seems to be only like straight
dudes who don't like me have something
negative to say about my appearance
you know what i mean like the average
like for example like a gay guy
who's more comfortable with his
sexuality will be like
well you're really good-looking or
something like not even in a hitting on
way or a woman will say something and
it's like
it turns out the spectrum of people who
are like feel compelled to come to my
page and say something negative about
look like assurance or whatever it's
like
turns out to look
a private profile you know your fat neck
beard haven't asked you you know
i've got time you know yeah some people
talk to me
i'll just put their picture like i'll
just be like yeah that's what they said
and then the next thing
i don't do that's the funniest thing
you're like brother the funniest [ __ ]
you do
you just share their turns and they're
all busted
yeah yeah oh just without a doubt and
you're either
you know coming from a private page or
you know
it's so funny or you just look like
mashed potatoes
[Laughter]
there's not a lot of male models in my
dms criticizing how
or am i or successful people or
successful you know
not a lot of people not a lot of blue
checks telling me i'm a failed actor so
much that's why it never
now if kevin hart was in there yeah
yeah but it's not bad
yeah but i also like here's the thing my
expectations for my own career it's like
i don't like with football where i was
like i never expected to be in the nfl
so
doing d3 [ __ ] was like oh that's cool i
found acting later in life
and i also like you know i haven't been
pursuing that necessarily straight
from the jump with this idea of like i
need to be
this famous or whatever so when i book a
job i'm like oh cool i didn't expect to
book any jobs during the pandemic and
then i got like you know tv shows and
commercials
and i'm like that's amazing yeah and i
never look beyond that i'm just like it
is what it is it's not up to me
i can be good at acting and that's all i
can worry about now you post more
stories than anybody i know
true i know
i never thought i'd be that guy
i never thought i'd be that guy but what
a lot of it is is
um hecka hey echoes trying to post memes
and and funny things that people
say to me you know look at him with his
cat okay with his cat
right that's my little cat spider when i
first got it
um the other funny thing that people
will say is like oh my god
it's lightweight it isn't even the worst
of it two days ago it looked like little
dots
oh yeah it's usually yeah how active i
am yeah it's insane hello so
look somebody calls me a big gay line
and then let's let's look at that person
i try to post a lot of memes this is
whatever i see you know oh look darren
till responded to me oh you went at it
uh-huh what till say uh he said are you
still arguing
like people are you still arguing till
you just read through 150 comments
on your page yeah till's fascinating to
me i don't i never punch down
you know i know good if you if you win
more fights i'll address it you know if
you if you get on a
run there i'll i'll drive my man and i
think he got like all he was doing i'm
just talking
some [ __ ] back there but in that he
seemed cool yeah
for sure like he was all his his little
buddies and there was a lot the reason
there's 150 comments here someone said
because all these
all these till dick riders were like
[ __ ] you you wouldn't [ __ ] step in a
cage oh my god he's gonna
yeah okay somebody want to pay me like a
half a million dollars a second occasion
till
sure let's do it i'm the least that's
not going to happen i'm the lisa till's
prom
his you know he was supposed to be the
guy man he was supposed to be the next
michael bisping
and it hasn't worked out for him yeah
i'm a fan and i wrote for the yeah like
i wanted to figure
[ __ ] out yeah and you know i'm sure this
instagram is great and all that and
maybe he gets you know uh positive
affirmation from his instagram stuff
like that that's
great yeah but when you tell eric
johanna you're dead broke it's like dude
that's not paying your bills get in the
gym and get focused
you're supposed to be the guy ufc gave
you every opportunity to be successful
yeah
headlining liverpool right it's woodley
and all this stuff
you were supposed to be the guy as of
now
you've been a failed guy yeah i don't
have time for it dude right until you
get
your [ __ ] together you won't get a word
out of me this is the most you get out
of me yeah and people are asking oh geez
is brandon telling you to comment i'm
like no i i'm talking [ __ ] on my own
until you told me i'm like yeah
you're you're like too i'm like no no
i i said would he steal another taxi
he's probably an oasis fan so i like him
yeah i know again we all know
i i hope he figures and i think he like
he took
my joke because i was just using the
format of like he's saying you shouldn't
be in the mma world and i'm like hey
maybe you shouldn't either
that's not a bear and so many dudes were
triggered like [ __ ] you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] you've
never accomplished anything like there
until
bro he does not hear about you bart got
tossed you know
today my god bart got time to need his
ass in the gym
that's what he needs to do yeah staff
instagram get in the gym bubble and i
wish him well
yeah can be one out of your last four
you know and then
you know walk around like you got a big
dick yeah you gotta get what happened
gotta get to work did he pull out of
victoria because of an injury
that's what he said yeah wait did you
hear the paulo costa thing that
somebody's
this meme was going around they're like
he didn't pull out of the fight with um
yeah they were like oh he had a he had a
hair transplant scheduled and there's
this meme of him like with his hair
shaved and like the marker around his
whoo paulo costa they were like he
didn't pull out because of money he
pulled up because he had a hair
transplant
yeah um which is just you know never
underestimated
definitely yeah right
okay yeah oh wait yeah did you see the
little let's see
there you go paul costa said he pulled
out oh wow of the jared cannon ear fight
because of how much the ufc was paying
him but in reality he was scheduled to
get a hair transplant surgery which
takes
six to 12 months to heal what's wrong
with his hair in that picture
i don't think you should get a hair
transplant if that guy's hair looks like
i know right yeah you know what i mean
like
i don't trust you yeah his hair looks
like biden he's out like yeah
his hair is awful hey dog i got you baby
i'm like well why don't you
do it yeah right oh wow he did the whole
thing i can't i'm surprised he let him
take all these pictures but he seemed
like he has good hair
oh my god oh [ __ ] let's get calling on
this
collin's done it twice i think yeah it
hasn't taken for granted yeah
that'd be rough because that's a lot of
money they might take photos because
it's a promotional thing i know a lot of
uh ig models will post
things that they get done to their
bodies i was like that can't be true
i know i thought it was like someone
said and even dana white was like dude
he's not in a position to negotiate for
more money which is
harsh but true yeah holy [ __ ] it looks
legit
holy [ __ ] that's really his ass he looks
so sedated right there yeah
when we see him now that's it that's the
transplant like he has a set of hair on
him now
yeah the [ __ ] [ __ ] words that's so
gross that's disgusting
look like a bunch of pimples yeah but
that was the
he doesn't want to go bulgy yeah yeah he
looks good bald though i don't know why
he wouldn't just go bald
yes i said i mean but he but that's his
real hair right there right
i don't know i think is that after
because it looks before to me because
that's what i'm saying like he looks
like he's always like maybe he has like
a bald spot in the back
from the front he looks fine it's just
that little spot let it be
that ball where are you baby yeah i
don't think you can wear them when you
fight though
that's fair no somebody said in the
comments i disapprove of this post
that's one day again that's his real
hair there oh okay
but you could see it's thinning though
right yeah right yeah it's very that's
just because of the sun
no sometimes
they don't always just get it like
coming back like that they'll be diffuse
thinning it gets real
like that's thin thing yeah that's
stunning so he did actually
go through it looks like this is and
that's why he pulled out the fight
but who knows when that video was taken
too but it looks like it but if you're
gonna get a hair transplant i don't give
a [ __ ] but yeah you know don't pull
other
you can pause whatever it's your money
and career yeah but then don't talk
[ __ ] to the ufc how you need to get paid
more yeah it just feels like it was a
lot of energy
like throwing up this smoke screen over
here of of
i wasn't getting paid enough i'm
surprised
i would have just said the hair
transplant oh hey i'm gonna get it lit
up you get a little bit of it yeah we
got lit up
yeah you should have just said no just
turn down the fight oh nevermind he
controlled the ufc so the ufc knew what
was up and
he's like hey i'm out for a year because
i'm getting a hair transplant they've
been like oh wow okay
yeah and then it when it came out and
then you know what you don't wouldn't it
wouldn't have been
actually the way to get a hair
transplant and then talk [ __ ] that's
the worst way to handle it oh the worst
way
i tried to help the guy out you see
trailer announced uh oscar de la hoya
yeah
bell for that's one of the current the
odds it's even money man
yeah mm-hmm i mean if you twerk and [ __ ]
you know resource in boxing
testing for this one no
which would be true for this yeah
either one spot you know negative for
that
i mean oscar and tesla's hot for cocaine
vitor or whatever yeah wait did they say
the fights september 11th of all dates
[Music]
hurtful on the 20-year anniversary
couldn't just i couldn't just wait
yeah a day i wonder how that's gonna
that i mean i can't do
great on [ __ ] pay-per-view that fight
no we're all gonna watch it though right
uh
you're gonna watch i'll watch i'm more
interested in jake paul tyrone
yeah for sure that's like a real what is
that one august august 26th
close august 26th yeah pretty good yeah
i feel like what are the stakes of this
like i know the stakes of the just two i
mean obviously vitor is a legend mma
de la hoya was a legend and boxing so
you got two old heads going at it
i'm coming like there's so much more
stakes for the you know the paul woodley
oh big time
yeah they're gonna have that fight on a
thursday
26 is thursday that's when i'm at brea
you sure yeah are you saying uh uh
jake yes uh is is 26 a thursday no it's
a saturday of this month
yeah oh no i'm august august is 26 of
this month right thursday
in august june type in when is
woodley jake i thought it was 26 maybe
it's not
yeah they definitely won't do it on
thursday
28th oh 28th so that's a saturday yeah
yep that makes more sense yeah yeah
thursday would be a bad idea
it's like i don't think they had fights
on thursdays
what do you got on that fight um which
one jake woodley
good fight where you shaking your head
jen no i mean it's exciting i i don't
know who's going to win you're basically
how crazy is that
tyron's a champion i don't yeah
depending how much woodley
food truck with jake just dropped too he
was talking about
i was asking him who he wanted to fight
he was like you know i want to fight
oohsman
in my head i'm like well that's never
happening because ufc contract they're
not going to have that
yeah allow that to happen and he's like
nate diaz he's like got [ __ ] ideas
i'm like dude nate can box bro yeah
but he you know he's going after these
ufc guys but dana's never gonna allow it
i wonder why the ufc guys the most
famous who else you can go for
like i mean somebody like nate diaz
makes sense but it's just as you're
saying it's not gonna happen
it'd be a tough fight jake although nate
actually was one of the first people to
like clap back at him um
online i think jake was talking [ __ ] to
mcgregor and nate was like
watch your [ __ ] mouth [ __ ] yeah yeah
he's like you're dealing with real
fighters man yeah
yeah makes sense what else you got jen
give him some curtains
i know i got into it with that vitor
fight
take a little break from the shenanigans
with mark the body harley cause guess
what
unlike mark with all the hair in the
world some of y'all losing your hair man
and two out of three men will experience
some form
of hair loss by the time that they're 35
more than
50 million bros out there suffer from
male pattern baldness
all right and with keeps they keep it
simple man stress-free way to keep your
hair
low-cost treatments start just ten
dollars per month keeps offers generic
versions
discreet little package shows up nobody
needs to know you looking like mark
harley these days
keeps has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors
prevention is key keep what you got
treatments can take four to six months
to see results
so if paulo casa did this probably been
fighting
so act fast if you're ready to take
action prevent hair loss go to keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com fighter to get your uh
first month of treatment free that's
keeps.com
fighter k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fighter
you know what man i made myself a
mexican and i don't speak spanish and
now i got a five-year-old and
one-year-old talking trash in spanish
well
guess what thank the lord for babble
because i
listen i took spanish and french in high
school i don't know
anything no bueno no bueno now babel
came along the number one selling
language learning app
there's a fun easy way to learn a new
language even if you're 38 you can still
learn dude
it's never too late especially when your
kids are talking trashy in spanish
when i know what they're saying okay see
poppy you know what i'm saying i got it
thanks to babel
babble 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language
on the go you can do it while you're
driving into work while you're on the
plane whatever it is you got 15 minutes
learn a goddamn language man other
language learning apps use ai for their
lesson plans but babble lessons created
by over 100
language experts their teaching methods
have been scientifically proven to help
you out
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian german we got it all man
we got it all start your new language
learn journey today with babylon right
now
you purchase a three-month babel
subscription you get an additional three
months free that's six months
for the price of three to learn a new
language that's priceless all right
just go to babel.com use the promo code
fighter that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code fighter for an extra three months
free babble language for life
cbd is the wild west or maybe you're
familiar with cbd like me my whole
family uses it
but you got your favorite brands and
you've been getting it from the same
place
but you wish it was easier you wish it
was cheaper well guess what i got
something for y'all
take all the guesswork out because
there's direct hem direct temp is
basically like
amazon of all the top cbd products you
can choose from dozens of products
from multiple brands get everything
shipped in one convenient box
your order all right everything's direct
from direct temp website
they also have helpful descriptions
icons of your page that explains
everything you need to know about the
products that you're buying they have
all the brands
all right all the brands what are you
looking for man they have all the top
rated brands in one simple interface one
simple page we're talking about
directhemp.com
they have a great customer service you
can ask questions we got you covered
sometimes it ships out the same day of
that you order it all right
they also add in a few little treats for
you to try other products out
you have 100 satisfaction guaranteed
to save 10 off everything on direct hem
including your top products that you're
probably buying
at a crazy expensive price gone over
direct temp
see how the price compares we got you
covered man uh try it out go to
directtemp.com
promo code is thick
c thick that's three c's for temps and
off all of the best cbd products
on the planet directamp.com promo code
thick
okay so the director of the fourth
jackass movie just
uh filed a restraining order against bam
shocking and we've had skibo on the show
before
and i guess now they've come out and
said that the reason why bam wasn't in
the movie is because
the one caveat to him being a part of
the production would be that he can't
get high
yeah and he just couldn't do that but
bam has gone bad on basically everybody
in the production saying that they're
trying to
use him as a puppet and then discard of
him stevo stevo
jumped on his comments it was like dude
we all love you everyone here loves you
but
you know we don't love it when you're
high and like you're the one who decided
to get loaded when they told you you're
not supposed to like this is on you you
made it up yeah yeah
it's always wild when people get like
that they make it about like
the people being like their team being
against them and it's like man you're
just struggling with you know with
it's always telling yeah i mean when
somebody is that convinced that
everybody around them is the problem
it's usually
obviously a red flag that oh yeah i
wonder if you can see it on dr
no he like recruited dr phil to be like
oh i saw him that same [ __ ] where he's
like
man everyone's against me and like my
mom what dr phil say
did he give him layups or was he no like
he was like he was he was
dr phillips i've heard dr phil's an
[ __ ] that's what i've heard
i've heard he's pretty good yeah i've
heard that oh [ __ ] yeah
good tv you know but i remember thinking
like oh this isn't you know his approach
was fair to bam
but also like hey letting him know like
you
obviously have some issues you're
working through with all these
substances and they talk to the people
who he's accusing of like undermining
him or doing whatever
you know he is doing a bunch of
different drugs and
it just doesn't matter has the tone of
somebody who's like he's just so upset
that like
other people are doing stuff and it's
this person it's that there was never
any
accountability did you see his threats
to that director he was like threatened
you know he was like
make sure you tell your yes goodbye he's
like you know what
yeah he's writing him death threats he
was talking about his family
in the letters as well as saying like
look at your kids
yeah write me a check it's really
unfortunate look at your children grab
your pocketbook and write a check if
you're a greedy and cheap look at your
children again
if you don't sign the paper look at your
children sign your stupid [ __ ]
contract before you're blank not safe
anymore
god damn wow that's so wild
but also i will say he had a great show
on mtv oh uh viva la bam
[ __ ] with his parents i always felt like
what felt bad for his dad
his dad you just he'd wake him up and
just start yeah just start punching them
all out
like i'm just like dude like and i get
like
[ __ ] with your parents to a degree
but it's just like i i yeah my my
response i was like oh i feel bad it was
like watching bum fights it's like i
feel bad for you yeah yeah
his dad's all big and shitty yeah yeah
it was a tragedy
yeah i never enjoyed that yeah and so i
i'm just making this connection of like
the kind of guy who would be like i know
a funny repeating joke i'm gonna let him
say [ __ ] on my dad wake him up at four
in the morning
that's not fun so and that's always why
like i'd never really like doing pranks
you know like wouldn't be on 50 central
be like oh you're doing a prank today
i'm like uh i hate going up to strangers
[ __ ] people like that yeah um and
some people are just more comfortable
with it so it's your fault
but i think for a band it's tough too
because remember he
kind of started he was kind of the
creator of jackass because he had uh
yeah because he had wait wasn't it
johnny knox it was johnny knox it was
bam he started way before that because
he had can't kill yourself videos
oh cky 2k yep and then that was that
went
way more viral than before jackass did
and that's where they
that's where they found bam and then
they brought bam on board because he was
already doing that stuff
but can't kill yourself was bigger was
before jack can't kill yourself
that's his bro that's his brother's band
cky and then they came out with the
video cky and bam bam was a legit
skateboarder pro oh yeah yeah
skated for toy machine elements so i
think for him it's like
it probably hits really hard yeah like i
mean the original originals i used to
watch videos
when i was in like [ __ ] fifth fifth
sixth grade yeah
like these old school likes and besides
johnny knoxville bam was making the most
i mean he was he was viva la bamba he
was making the band was big but
he had like he had a bunch of real
estate like he had a business like he
was like
did you have a purple lamborghini at one
point oh yeah yeah no stupid
yeah that thing was fire yeah can't kill
yourself it's [ __ ] big man
it looks a little rough in that one oh
yeah well
for for him it all went downhill once
his friend ryan dunn died his best yeah
and died in a
gt3 rs that was crazy i remember when
that happened that was fun that was
crazy
chappelle when you were drinking did you
ever go to bars and like just talk with
random people or like
no i sat there by myself
okay i'm sick of [ __ ] going to these
bars and
hanging out with nobody's and just kind
of reminded me of like to be an
alcoholic like unless you're just
drinking privately like
you go to a bar it's kind of like
everybody's your friend now or whatever
you know i was kind of like
like i just kind of like like just
[ __ ] introvert
yeah just drinking a partner in crime
would drink with you like a go-to buddy
no i didn't need no help i could do this
alone is a little bit different when
you're a celebrity and it's kind of like
yeah it was just up to you yeah i go to
like these little like dive bars and
kind of just sit there by myself like
now if you're an alcoholic like you'd be
like
the most popular guy oh yeah yeah back
flip
i can still land them drunk though yeah
that yeah 100 out of 100.
yeah that is well yeah but i mean you
know like yeah
needless to say it does suck that like
this is the round that like
it's going because i mean i've i've
always [ __ ] loved i was watching that
john belushi um
doc last night even him they like they
have a interview you know he was
great really hardcore addict so he was
doing something with the blues brothers
and jumped off stage and broke his leg
and then they put him on painkillers and
like once he got started in painkillers
he never stopped
and then from painkillers it went to you
know heroin like hardcore drugs yeah and
he was a straight addict
and then people like this is the 70s for
you like
he was missing saturday night live
because he was [ __ ] getting high and
like
that's what going to rehab but then we
call into the show and they made a joke
out of it
like it was nuts like we would never
imagine that today
and then then they have them i it looks
like he's at the store i don't know
where he's
he's right by the store it's these two
guys interview him and like when
last when you were here last year nobody
knew your name now everybody knows who
you are
and he's like how does it feel that
everybody knows who you are he's like i
mean they
i guess they know my name they don't
know he goes they don't know me yeah
he's like i don't know those people yeah
you can tell he's like super lonely
yeah super he's like they don't know me
man he's like that's pretty interesting
statement because it is kind of like
today like people
i mean if you really think about it like
being a you know celebrity or something
like it
i feel like that's still in the play
like people know your name
yeah they don't like know you no no no
well think of if you're if john blue she
was doing that
now ann was into social media imagine
his comments
like if he just went m.i.a on a huge
show
because of drugs his comments he'd get
lit the [ __ ] up and they seized that
think about the mentor that would
[ __ ] yeah tailspin
[ __ ] it yeah it's heartbreaking man i
remember talespin
what else you got jen okay so this only
fans model along with seven of her
friends rented out
a house for a week in i believe it was
naples florida
they spent a little over 20 shout out to
naples
they spent a little over 26 grand for
the spot
and once they unloaded their stuff and
they unpacked they decided to have a
barbecue they got in bikinis started
having a good time
and she took this photo posted it on
instagram
shortly after the owners of the home uh
said that they were all gonna be kicked
out of the rental property because
they did a quick search of all of their
social media posts
and they found out she was the only
fan's mom so they assumed that she was
doing porn they had a strict rule about
not doing
oh they're 60. they're definitely older
yeah oh yeah
she said that her along with all her
friends already told them like hey we're
not filming porn we're not doing
that we're just here to relax do some
yoga maybe record like yoga content but
we're not
naked we're not doing porn but they got
kicked out because she
is on only fans is what she's stating
i'm not sure actually she could be
somebody who post nude on only fan she
could be somebody who posts like
instagram comment just behind a paywall
content yeah yeah so i don't really know
what type of stuff she makes but she's
saying that
she doesn't do porn and she got kicked
out of this rental property because
she's like a student
elderly folk that didn't know yeah but i
mean for a while only fans was
yeah absolutely
who else would it be i mean to be fair
i think the owners assumed
assumptions aren't like terrible neck on
the throat yeah that's the one that's a
little
bit pointy but oh this one oh yeah
what do you think is going on yes
yeah she had a piece of steak yeah you
can see why the owners would they
probably went to her instagram like okay
this is yeah
yeah yeah yeah i bet her only fans
pretty lit
yeah i feel like you think
to see what was going on they were like
before we kick you out like let's just
get the husband maybe the husband i'm
just gonna
as a background character i don't want
to make anything you need to confirm
that she's doing porn
she's a super baddie but yeah she's
beautiful
but with the yeah i mean as a homeowners
it is their house
they don't want that in the house yeah
all right
26 grand though they're balling yeah
that's for a week
three thousand dollars per person that
was a little over
for a week they were only sitting there
for a week and it cost
uh twenty six thousand four hundred
dollars
yeah so she's clearly killing it only
fans if she can afford that
killing it that only fans probably
pretty lit yeah she's probably so i can
take out the only thing
maybe she definitely is yeah i mean
after that little choke she sucks that's
why i got her kicked
see that post definitely got her only
fancy uh subscription bump
right yeah now everyone's talking about
it better
like your mother oh true everything i've
never heard
you look at a profile jesus christ yeah
i feel like every time one of these
stories goes
viral about like a girl getting fired or
kicked out of something because her only
fans it helps them ultimately
except for that girl that sucked off all
the sun's members like apparently she uh
not doing it
oh yeah but she wasn't really like an
only fans person she was like a ig
model i hate to use the word thought but
like you know what i mean
she was doing that before she was only
fans she probably would have used that
word about herself
yeah i know yeah the fact that she
expressed that she sucked all seven days
apparently it's not going well for her
she's like i lost my job
kicked off the internet yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah she kicks out the internet
the internet was like damn
okay this is like a little attachment
about uh uh to that last story but only
fans
recently got a valuation of one billion
dollars because they're promoting only
fans tv
where they're doing cooking shows and
fitness shows weird
they're trying to go more of the patreon
route now where you can't have sex stuff
on there
but they're trying to branch out into
different avenues yeah
somebody told me they were like oh you
can do it only fans and they just have
to be like a lifestyle content
a lot of people do that yeah and that's
cool like and you can get people to
like pay money to look at your vacation
pictures it's that's awesome
yeah but i would never start an only fan
like i always do between the two patreon
because only fans has the stigma
yeah you know you don't want to be going
like as a guy stand up for my only fans
that'd be tough a lot of guys have
stigma would be rude
you know who i got out has an only fans
from love island
do you remember that guy lucy was dating
the sandwich guy
uh sam oh yeah yeah yeah he has only
fans where he makes sandwiches
yeah does it do well i don't know i
don't know
but he has a free account he's british
right
yeah where he shows you how to make his
favorite sandwiches that's how you hook
them in that's how you put that
people i don't know the longevity of
that after you know after a while like
six sandwiches yeah okay i know right
yeah
[Laughter]
okay this is a sad story um in san jose
a few days ago
there was a 32 year old man at a bar
and he was very drunk he was getting a
little belligerent he got kicked out for
being drunk and trying to lift up a
woman's shirt
he later got kicked out him and a 24
year old woman
walked towards his car and i guess they
decided to get it on because she started
giving him head
they both didn't know that yes inside
the car they both
didn't know that the car was in reverse
and they were going 45 miles per hour
backwards so fast that they crashed into
the bar
and hit somebody who was dining outside
imagine being in a car going 45 and
thinking it was stationary
in reverse but in reverse in reverse
yeah while getting your dick sucked
they hit that person right there yeah
and the woman unfortunately and it's the
way
rock yeah must be an unreal head for him
not to realize he's gone
he must have been so hammered yeah going
backwards at 45 miles an hour yeah
he doing time i wonder what happens with
the girl
uh i don't know that's a great question
would she be considered an accomplice to
it yeah like
do you think she's gonna head to jail
i had to i apologize i just
just off the dome
oh he's [ __ ] yes he's super super he
doing tom that girl would be
yeah no she effectively is driving by
sucking his dick she could get behind
the wheel
i don't think he was intending to drive
like i don't think they got in the car
and they were trying to drive
off they got in the car so he could get
head yeah
and then he just put it in reverse on
accident that's what they're trying to
say i don't know i could charge her with
involuntary man sucker but i don't
see yourself mark yeah
yeah cause she didn't physically start
the car and she's like i didn't [ __ ]
tell him to put him in reverse or hit
the gas
he's just here to suck dick but if you
get pulled over
if you're driving and you get pulled
over and the girls poor
performing head on you don't they get
don't wouldn't both you get arrested for
like isn't that like um
if you're sucking somebody's dick while
they shoot somebody are you responsible
yeah like if you're sucking a dude
that's a good point
i think having sex in a car is like in
public isn't it like
i think yeah so having sex in a car is
like the private sector
going away for like 10 years like he is
i bet he gets eight to ten
yeah you think just eight to ten yeah
maybe like voluntary mentality is she a
sex offender now is that like with
public indecency would that would she
get that oh
i bet that sounds like you're probably
gonna get charged with a lot yeah she's
gonna have to introduce herself to all
the neighbors
i'm a sex offender hopefully she taught
him a thing or two before he goes
uh our boy jay park is in the news
that's our boss is he uh as a cream pop
star okay but he's he made it here in
the u.s also the manager of uh
zombies yeah part of the management team
party yeah his uh his company represents
yeah
something like that so what's so he's
accused of cultural appropriation
because he did this video
like a a cover of kendrick lamar's dna
dna
which i love that video yeah uh but this
i'll just show you what jay park did
here let me see this is just a sample of
it he actually made the youtube video
private now because of all the
controversy
he's he's big though it's not like he's
enormous he's huge
he sounds like kendrick people are mad
at the way they're dressed yep
what it's basically just the way they're
dressed also the braids
dreadlocks that kind of stuff so they're
saying he's trying to
jack their culture what but he he made a
really good response saying like you
know
he's inspired by you know black and
latino culture let me see when the beat
drops jen all right
oh it's
have you guys seen the japanese cholos
yes yeah yeah
that's it it's a huge board yeah it's
huge
huge cold days too who gives a [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah who cheers
apparently it's cold now is cultural uh
culture appropriation now because
apparently someone who got a tan
they were getting backlash for it
because like it it was just something
they know you're trying to jack cards
they're trying to
yeah here's one little metric that i
always think about these asian cellos
they look hardcore are you taking it to
profit
and then pretend like it's not from
somewhere else because if you're
acknowledging the source
like jay park did yeah yeah i'm
motivated by kendrick lamar this is
actually
almost like i could see the problem if
you're like oh yeah i invented this yeah
yeah he was like nine vented sagging
pants and braids yeah like that'd be an
issue but if you're giving credit to the
source
and also not like using it to like i
also want to
answer something else i also wonder how
many people are actually mad
yeah yeah yeah because i probably i bet
you most
yeah it's probably a lot of white people
it was enough for him to make his video
private though so i'm sure his you know
his managers and agents
white people yeah there's a lot of angry
white people exactly
um i wanted to get your opinion on this
brandon because this is sean strickland
who's got who has a fight
pretty soon he was grappling with this
guy oh yeah
talking about this really yeah this guy
is so this guy is orlando sanchez like
a black belt and he's just like yeah
he's pretty popular in the
jujitsu circuit so sean says that he did
some moves that you just don't do
training no no it's with his arm he got
an underhook yeah and he like rolled
with his underhook and then did he crank
it
yeah god he is thick
thick and short
oh yeah is that too much right there too
yeah it's definitely frowned upon and
he's so much bigger
it's coming up it'll come up in a bit
looking for the smoke
is that [ __ ] up yes right there
he jacked he just he did this to his arm
why bro why
whoa get away
oh what the [ __ ] man why dude
it's definitely a dirty move yeah it's a
dirty move yeah that's what i want her
to know super yeah i mean
also with somebody who he's got so you
know you have a fight coming up yeah
we're killing his goddamn elbow joint
what did chael say about it
chael was like if it happens once and
then it happens again it's almost like
it kind of
in a way vindicates him doing it because
he's like oh he doesn't it's like an
instinct
which is you know the most favorable
interpretation we basically know that
that's a dirty move like you're
purposely trying to twerk i mean it
reminds me of working with bigger guys
especially for the guy
it's like don't [ __ ] do that you're
you're throwing your weight around and
it's not cool but like
yeah chael's chase you know he has a
fight coming up yeah
it's like what are you doing chael's
angle was it vindicates the first time
doing it because you can see that all he
knows when somebody gets an underhook is
to do that but it's like
then i think that i wouldn't train with
him to be a german shepherd
yeah i wouldn't then i wouldn't that guy
he can't train with that guy then if
he's that dirty it's just like easy to
break someone's like like he kept like
like
it's like basically like oh yeah yeah
yeah so if you're trying to get that
you have something like if you can do
that quickly with a lot of force you can
dislocate your shoulder
it's also just like there's you also
you're
you you just get the the point there is
for an injury yeah it's not like
you know yeah i'd be pissed too i don't
know if i'd hit
back fist him in the face oh this is my
guy right here oh you're talking about
sons did you see this one's in four yeah
sons of four dogs somebody who's
messaging me like you guys should have
uh tell brenda to bring him on fire to
the kid
i know we were going to oh nick was
talking we were having my king to sting
but kingston's gonna come out
next week so okay he's probably not
going to be popular anymore
bro this dude beat the [ __ ] out he did a
hockey move
he did the hockey move got him the
journey kept going and [ __ ] beating the
[ __ ] out of town
i love i love how that dude tried to
just sucker punch a beautiful thing
that's why this is beautiful because i
hate sucker punchers oh this guy got
what he deserved
sun's in four and then his team he even
looks like a
yeah he misses then he's like all right
[ __ ] yo first of all [ __ ] that haircut
the simple jack cholo yeah what
and then watch oh yeah i want you too
look he's still holding him down i know
and boom upper i want to shout that's
how we do it
he literally looks away it comes back
what if there's another presence of mine
to stand the sun's
applaud that kind of ruthlessness first
of all look at this
shitty dj calendar and then he got
[ __ ] up denver's most wanted who
didn't chime in either
yeah yeah unfortunately those are denver
broad guys
i really want to say that's how we get
down in phoenix but i mean this is
from time to time yeah yeah not often
the phoenix fan was from denver
apparently
somebody who says yeah i guess so this
is somebody who's telling me but even
booker got
uh got it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
sons and right everybody's been foreign
the the him holding up before what a
legend
what a legend shout out to that dude
i don't know his name but and the the
video you you wouldn't care but it's
that guy tried sucker punch him so he's
kind of dedicated yeah yeah no that was
good
i like that i thought it was sons oh we
talked about this before
jessica brown who put gorilla glue in
her hair yeah and had to go to the
hospital
so she has her own hairline now forever
hold
but good for her for turning this
[ __ ] tragedy into
she did something with it hopefully it
goes well
what was she thinking i know but then
cat
you mentioned that some people actually
put a little bit yeah i think chappelle
was telling me that there are certain
people no barbara i told you guys actual
barber like [ __ ] i used gorilla
yeah it was like doing some dudes hair
yeah wow but she like
yeah there was she got a little dabba do
you in the shade
in the punk rock scene too there's
always this like like i used like egg
whites in my hair before when i oh yeah
oh the hell yeah it's like there was
this different like
you'd always hear like some different
thing and would you have liberty
or no just regular spikes but i remember
like at some point i
like went to school one time with egg
whites in my hair yeah but it is it's
like
it's like gel the picture of you in the
the picture you in the uh
regular show
at that point it's a really inefficient
use of eggs
but stuff i mean like you know you would
hear like elmer's glue right because
if you have a huge [ __ ] mohawk like
hairspray isn't really going to do it
you know what i mean to
get all your hair so stick that [ __ ]
yeah you want it right yeah but also
don't do that yeah also just don't wear
that hairstyle
yeah let it be man but also don't do
vlogs are dope bro
this dude from the casualty his name's
jake he used to have like the
sickest like the biggest [ __ ] mohawk
you don't see a lot of
jake from the casualty very impractical
yeah you don't you don't still care you
don't see anybody with it these days
well look forward to his [ __ ] used to be
[ __ ] him
your buddy uh tim armstrong oh yeah tim
armstrong
that's so you're the one with the yellow
that's the yellow word scroll down
but is that a wig a little no that's not
a wig that's his hair that's him back in
the day
yeah that's just a little accessory it's
just [ __ ] dope man this [ __ ] is hard
that [ __ ] [ __ ] i might do it because it
will make my calling
hard pass if you're an actual peacock
that's great
that's the whole band there all of them
did it the casualties yeah
those are guys they look ridiculous nah
they're they're amazing
the guy from um uh big daddy the spit
they got in my mouth
like the singer spitting to the camera
your dad not me okay
uh yeah he the the singer was singing
and he was spitting into the crowd
and one of the spits landed in my mouth
not from this band where are you going
yeah oh dude i was like what do you spit
in your mouth
were you happy spinning around no oh i
was like i thought you got
this it kind of drunk oh
oh my god what were you more mad about
that or when uh my armpits went when
you're backwards
right he's just standing over me i'm
waiting for him i know i was i was
bitching
a little just like one drop right
uh the spit was probably the worst
because it was like a lookie
yeah you swallowed it i just swallowed
it oh you spit it i spit it right back
and you're still fanning i was like
rubbing my tongue
it's like the program you know
was my first time seeing him i was so
yeah i was so stoked because that was
like my band around that time sounds
like a hater
[ __ ] dude he seems pretty racist
no he was spitting on everybody it
wasn't just me yeah yeah he's just
spitting losers
other people other people were just like
spitting on all the black guys
i've actually heard that about a couple
bands i was talking to a security guard
who was telling me that follow the lead
singer fallout boy spits a lot and like
you know the security guards have to
stand there and
get spit on left and right yeah and when
you think about it they're singing they
don't have a lot of time to like
swallow between verses you think people
in the audience are like this
[ __ ] spitting
but like at punk shows there's not like
security guards like that there's no
like no barricades because everyone's
just kind of like [ __ ]
all over the place so like we were like
you're on stage off stage you're
on stage
like blurring the lines between a
performer audience huh
i'm not cool and you know what
i mean i [ __ ] still love that man to
this day and it was what's funny fast
forward
you're right or down all right i went
and saw them like years later everyone
saw
dylan she spin my [ __ ] mouth i'm not
gonna be a fan
anymore yeah but you all throw away all
the right
but you got to see the lead cigarette
leaves because you got to see what he
looks like you got to see his teeth
waiting on what casualties
uh george jorge
you're in a band in this world you can
spin my [ __ ]
oh my god
bro look at look at the top the the far
right the top far right where he's like
oh yeah that was that guy's [ __ ] got
in your mouth
but not i'm not intentionally did you
get the black plague like how
he doesn't look healthy i survived
covenant
right you've got the og vaccine right
there
vaccinated for life clearly he's not
no he's uh i think he's got those
english teams he might be
he's from new york he might be puerto
rican i don't know that's terrible yeah
a lot of british vibes from those teeth
is that like his trademark to pick his
nose
i don't know are your horse teeth is
straightforward
looks like he has alpaca i don't know
where he's from i can't i can't remember
where he's like before he went down to
earth god's like come here let me just
[ __ ] redeem it
his teeth look like those fake like
mouse that you put in
those uh well those were modeled off
something it was yeah you know
and they're really yeah it was yeah i
mean think about that i can't believe
you spit
from that dude you're telling me punk
rockers don't have the best oral hygiene
is that what i'm saying
i would rather i remember when i when i
became like when i started kicking all
these punks i go what no one [ __ ]
showers no one likes to brush their
teeth yeah well that was [ __ ]
the changing part about it because it's
like so diy like low maintenance like we
don't give a [ __ ] we don't shower but
then like you're spending an hour on
your hair
yeah oh yeah i guess that's where all
the grooming energy goes yeah
[ __ ] that yeah yeah no yeah oh yeah
government
it's [ __ ] it's still on i'll still go
see the casualties to this day but they
they have a new lead singer and years
later when i went and saw them
that uh i actually got to sing a song
with them so it was like kind of like a
did you say i was like hey man uh and
you said i'm like hey man your old
singer spit in my mouth yeah and you
guys
are telling that no i didn't tell them
that oh that'd be the first thing
[Laughter]
now when you performed with them did you
spit in anyone's mouth no i did not i
don't
i don't spit hashtag paid for it gross
you got a video of that anywhere i kind
of want to see it that'd be safe
of you on stage singing with them uh
yeah i'd rather i'd rather that
horrendous tooth man piss on me than
spit in my mouth
i'd rather take his weird dick out and
piss all over his weird
picture for sure oh here it is p
sanitary
here chin uh-huh let's see it we get the
one of chappelle on the
the third one there chin of him no it
i said i'm sending to you through uh but
you have to get out of here soon to
[ __ ] practice with your band hey
hey what do you always say to me you
want to make your reality based angles
that [ __ ] trap song yeah oh wait no
scroll down my instagram it's on my
instagram
this one here definitely no different
one go scroll
i mean this was years ago right no i had
posted it not too long ago
keep going it's on here my money was
funny
my money was funny keeps going
go a little quicker chance how far down
wait hold on i just i just sent the
video right there
all right it hit accept i did
the photo i got want to be in the pit
too
look at me
oh look at her look at the guy with the
mohawk
you see me where is it which one's
right now i sent you another one chin
that's me in the pit
are you the one crouch surfing no i'm
not not that rude he's the one
the only black guy in the video yeah
[Applause]
look at this
i live my best life [ __ ]
that yellow that picture you in the
yellow shirt is you look like eric
griffin
mixed with martin lawrence and that a
little bit thank you that's a nice one
were those my glasses yeah
mm-hmm it's being a rancid t-shirt
all right get off my profile yeah it
looks like a snapchat filter
you could zoom it in on that i think
that's my glasses my old glasses oh
those are yours yep that is chimps you
look like martin lawrence and um
uh blue streak in that i do yeah a
little bit why thank you
he's a good no he wasn't he's a good
looking that's why i said thank you yeah
i know yeah because originally i did
want to box his ass but then i saw this
video and i was like i don't want to do
that
i had to step back you know i had to
pull from the fight as they called it
make sense
you're gonna have a hair transplant
coming up no i don't know what else you
got jen
uh one more sure it's just this uh so
usually black bears and grizzly bears
are
cordial they're cool but these are both
hungry so you'll see this
special
[Laughter]
oh man hold up let me refresh this
it's crazy watching bears [ __ ] go at
it
where's the black bear you'll see it
so he's running after right now [ __ ] but
luckily the black bear
can climb a tree [ __ ] out of here
dude oh he's a little guy too
yeah they say black bears can climb a
lot higher than white bears
or they can jump higher too see he's
trying to get him you can't oh that's
great dude brown bear's not crawling no
trees
well grizzlies at least too big they
weigh too much [ __ ]
chabot you were saying black bears have
more fast twitch muscle fibers yeah i
think so
yeah extra muscle as you call it it's a
little black bear
yeah he was gonna eat him he would eat
him yeah
is that good yeah that's it all right
kids that is
it uh we got new dates
l.a i'm at ha ha's comedy club that is
july 16th through the 17th
friday saturday la's finally [ __ ]
back open man so july 16th through 17th
me and some friends will be at hahas in
l.a
uh the only one on there i don't think
ticks are available yet but the big boy
for me is
san antonio september 26 27th
at the atnt center out there in san
antonio
those things be on sale soon that's a
big one for your boy
what do you got oh and then the new
thick boy merch drops next friday
friday morning new thick all new thick
boy merch sleeveless hoodies
and think boy shorts drop next friday at
thickboy.com
i i kept saying lutherville timonium but
i guess that's just baltimore
yeah so i'm going to say baltimore i
just put baltimore in that yeah i don't
know why i did that
uh july 15th through the 17th magus joke
house
and then the one i'm really super super
excited for is
brayden and probably that'll be fun
finally getting my shot
you know i'm excited dude good for you
yeah mr august 26th
mr mark the body harley just um you know
a new
episode of side hustle premiering july
17th i think
is um i actually don't know the dates
but i think there is another couple
episodes that i'm in that are going to
drop
and uh you know i'll just be in north
carolina next week shooting an equipment
sausage commercial
you can catch me in
you [ __ ] up i did you [ __ ] that's okay
you know i'll respond to you and just
i i'll be shooting the commercial all
day so i don't know i mean dudes want to
take pictures with you outside of gyms
you know hey we could do it you know and
then brian's in
uh these are the funny bone right now
albany new york you'll see brian
uh june and 18-19 i think that's uh
friday saturday
yeah go get tickets see brian count
tickets for all of us at fatkz.com
that's it kids love you see ya love ya